la lucha de la mujer latinoamericana se
potenció en los últimos años las voces
por la despenalización del aborto han
tenido respuesta en países como
argentina colombia o chile porque los
derechos reproductivos son una
herramienta poderosa contra la violencia
de género
primero que todo muchas gracias y unirme
a todas las toda la fortaleza que
muestra el movimiento de mujeres en cada
uno de los países del mundo como bien
decís la autonomía reproductiva de las
mujeres es hace parte de la agenda
histórica del feminismo desde tiempos
muy lejanos y ahora lo que estamos
viendo es cómo se consolidan esos
derechos en las legislaciones en cada
victoria que hemos tenido en la agenda
legislativa o en las cortes sobre este
sobre esta materia nos impulsa a seguir
luchando por los derechos que nos faltan
y de otra parte el feminicidio es una
epidemia en el mundo en américa latina
hay una particular desprotección a la
vida de la mujer y a la defensa de sus
derechos para teclear el abuso qué tan
mal estamos
la verdad es que nosotros tenemos una
honda preocupación con este tema pero
también hay que aclarar que los datos
sobre femicidio suelen ser bastante
discutibles ciertamente por ejemplo para
el caso argentina que son datos que
conozco en la oficina de la corte dijo
para 2020 que cada 32 horas una mujer
muere por feminicidio pero lo que sucede
en otros países es que seguramente esta
cifra se incrementa y lo que no hemos
podido hacer es que las medidas o las
leyes que se implementan reduzcan los
homicidios
producidos y que tienen está tipificada
penal
es una epidemia seguramente y como lo
veremos en las cifras que salgan de los
distintos países y van a mostrar
incrementos en estas realidades también
luchamos para que se terminen los
femicidios que los estados garanticen
una vida libre de violencia contra las
mujeres y finalmente muy rápidamente le
pregunto cómo nos libramos de las
masculinidades tóxicas que mal definen a
nuestro lugar en el mundo
y toda la tarea cultural que me parece
que el feminismo también ha contribuido
a que lo vemos como problema social
las formas en las que hacer relacionan a
hombres y mujeres las hemos interpelado
a las estereotipación es no en el cómo
deben ser las mujeres o como deben ser
los hombres que nos enseñaron desde
pequeñas y pequeños vienen siendo
cuestionadas por el movimiento y me
parece que buena parte o quiero creer
que una parte importante de los varones
va poco a poco comprendiendo que su
comportamiento tiene que ver con el
fenómeno de la violencia que no
solamente es un comportamiento
individuación que también es social pero
que su contribución es muy importante
las relaciones en su familia en sus
lugares de trabajo en sus con sus padres
hacen que podamos con la conciencia que
vayan ganando los varones podamos ir
reduciendo también este fenómeno de
violencia ellos son muy importantes en
ese trabajo cultural que el feminismo
inicial